and thank you for joining us at 11 I'm
Brian Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez less
than two months after the last Chief
resigned the Henderson Police Department
has named a new leader eight news now
investigator Kyle Payne has more on the
hiring of deputy chief Holly Chadwick
Holly Chadwick will be the eighth police
chief there in Henderson since 2005
today we spoke with the Henderson city
councilwoman who told us this new Chief
is up to the task of taking over a
department with low morale she's a
deputy chief there now on the forge for
21 years her appointment comes after the
last Chief Cedric Andres retired after
two votes of no confidence from the
police Union the chief before that is
suing the city of Henderson after she
got fired there's a lot of finger
pointing in that lawsuit but in
Henderson they hope this hiring will put
a stop to that trend
will this new chief
stop whatever's been going on well I
believe that Chief Chadwick will build
the morale she's a person that
definitely gets involved with her
officers and has already been doing a
bang-up job as a deputy chief
and it's it's morale that needs building
absolutely it does deputy chief Michael
blow has been the interim police chief
since the end of February Chadwick went
to UNLV for her bachelor's and her
Masters and also graduated from the FBI
National Academy